here's what would happen if the  megalodon was hiding in the mariana  trench  from its home 11 kilometers below the  surface this enormous shark would swim  to the upper reaches of the pacific  ocean and feed at night returning to the  deep during the day  to maintain body temperature at these  depths our megalodon would have to be  warm blooded and to navigate in total  darkness it would either have to become  bioluminescent or grow massive eyes like  the giant squid  its skin might evolve to enable more  tactile ways of feeling its way around  an expandable stomach would help it  store food and inward facing teeth would  prevent slimy prey from escaping but  with all these modifications  this wouldn't be the terrifying  megalodon we've heard about so  you can plan your trip to the mariana  trench knowing you wouldn't be eaten  because